les week-ends où l'on célébrait aussi la
toussaint au cours d'eau messe
particulière marquée par l'attentât de
10 jeudi dernier les croyants ont pu se
réunir dans les églises malgré le
confinement les lieux de culte était
sous protection policière
reportage à la cathédrale saint louis de
blois terrorisme confinement liberté de
culte
cette messe du 1er novembre à la
cathédrale saint louis est en tout point
extraordinaire protection de la police
municipale à l'entrée présence de la
police nationale durant la messe
trois jours après l'attentât la
basilique notre dame à nice les croyants
catholiques sont nombreux une manière de
lutter contre l'obscurantisme
on n'a pas peur parce que nous sommes
des chrétiennes à perdre et la mort ne
peut pas tenir avec d'esprit et non on
n'a pas peur c'est répondre par l'amour
à la violence pas n'aurait pas le béni
oui oui n'est de béni nul au smec par
l'ape est déjà après l'assassinât du
professeur d'histoire-géographie samuel
pâti des représentants des communautés
musulmanes du loir-et-cher avait fait
part au diocèse de leurs émotions et
avaient indiqué qu'ils seraient présents
à la messe une dizaine d'entre eux ont
partagé ce moment on est solidaire de ce
qui s'est passé
et on vient présenter aujourd'hui de
toute évidence il ya aussi en signe de
paix de fraternité envers nos frères
chrétiens d confine exceptionnellement
et avec dérogations les croyants ont pu
assister à la messe en ce jour de la
toussaint et l'évêque de blois de
plaider pour ce qu'il appelle un
déconfinement des esprits je ne pense
pas personnellement que le danger
sanitaire soit plus grand dans une
église que sur un lieu de travail on dit
aux gens aller travailler ou dans une
école on dit aux élèves à l'école et
donc on n'est pas dans la configuration
du premier confinement après les
décisions ultime m'appartiennent corps
et bien entendu respectera ici aussi
longtemps qu'il faudra le faire ce qui
ne sera demandée les évêques veulent
désormais écrire au ministre de
l'intérieur responsable des cultes
après une réunion cette semaine par
visioconférence